Çeviri: Eren Gokce
Gözden geçirme: Erman Turkmen
Ahmet Naç
Yeni Nesil Öğretmen
Gördüğünüz gibi
boya fırçamla geldim.
Kendisi benimle özdeşleşmiş durumda.
Bundan üç hafta kadar önce,
sadece bir öğretmen olarak anılırken,
artık boyacı öğretmen
olarak anılmaya başladım.
Tabii, bundan şikâyetçi değilim.
Ama bunu getirme amacım
tamamen bugün dikkat çekmek için.
Çünkü biz ilkokul öğretmenleri
derslerde sınıfımıza girerken,
böyle değişik materyaller kullanırız
ve üzerimize ilginç kostümler giyeriz.
Bugün de ben en iyi bildiğim iş
olan öğretmenliği yapacağım,
sizleri de ilkokul birinci
sınıfa götürmek istiyorum.
Şunu izninizle biraz dekorunuzu
bozacağım ama bırakmak istiyorum.
Evet. Hiç vakit kaybetmeden başlayalım.
Dersimiz, Hayat Bilgisi.
Konumuz Mustafa Kemal Atatürk'ün hayatı.
Şimdi, aman hocam diyeceksiniz.
Haklısınız.
İlkokulda, ortaokulda, lisede ve
üniversitede yaklaşık olarak
on beş sene boyunca
Atatürk’ün hayatını gördük.
Nasıl başlıyor?
Mustafa Kemal Atatürk,
1881 yılında Selanik’te doğdu.
Evin fotoğrafını
hatırlıyorsunuz değil mi?
Hepinizin gözünde canlanmıştır muhakkak.
En çok o hatırlanır zaten.
Sonra babasının adı Ali Rıza Bey,
annesinin adı Zübeyde Hanım.
İşte kız kardeşi Makbule.
Kargalar. Efendime söyleyeyim, askerlik.
İşte şurada yaptı, şöyle bir lider,
şöyle bir asker,
ve en son Anıtkabir'de biter.
Bu sanırım 15 sene boyunca
bizim hem öğretmenlerimiz,
hem üniversitelerde hocalarımız
tarafından bizlere aktarılan
Mustafa Kemal Atatürk’ün hayatının
genel hatları bu şekilde.
Bir kez daha anlatmak istiyorum
Atatürk'ün hayatını ama bu kez farklı.
İlk durağımız Suriye.
Mustafa Kemal Atatürk, harp
akademisinden mezun olduğunda
kurmay yüzbaşı olarak ilk kıta
vazifesine Suriye’ye gidiyor
ve orada gizli olarak Vatan
ve Hürriyet Cemiyeti'ni kuruyor.
Ve o cemiyetin eğitim kolu
reisliğini üstleniyor.
Cepte.
1915, Çanakkale Savaşı.
Anafartalar'ın en kanlı günleri.
Mustafa Kemal Atatürk, bir gün
çadırında oturmuş, lambasını yakmış
ve masasının üzerinde
bir şey çiziyor. Ne olabilir?
Latin harflerinin şablonunu
çıkarıyor. Bakın 1915.
Bir sene sonraya gidelim.
1916, aylardan Kasım.
Doğu cephesine atanıyor.
16. Kolordu Komutanı olarak
ve orada çökme tehlikesi
yaşayan orduyu çiçek gibi alıyor.
Günlerce süren muharebenin
sonunda kısa süreli bir iki saatlik
istirahati sırasında Kurmay Başkan
İzzettin Çalışlar ile bir sohbeti var.
Maddeler hâlinde sıralanmış.
Kadınlara serbestlikten falan
bahsediyor ama ilk madde çok ilginç.
Aynen söylüyorum.
Muktedir ve aile hayatına
vâkıf valide yetiştirmek.
Günümüzde – afili bir kelime
kullanayım – güçlü anne eğitimi.
Bakın savaştan çıkmış, bir soluklanması
gerekiyor, değil mi?
Bir soluklan değil mi, bir otur. Hayır.
Sivas’a geliyoruz.
Sivas kongresi, Sivas günleri.
Amerikalı gazeteci Mr. Brown
ile bir röportajı var.
Diyor ki, Türk halkı iyi bir eğitim
görmelidir. Eğitim okul demektir.
Türk köylüsünün pek azı okur yazardır.
Ancak bakın burasına dikkat,
yeniliklere isteklidir.
Çocuklarının iyi bir
eğitim almasını ister.
Sivas’ta! Hani düzenli ordu
kursaydık önce değil mi?
Hani düşman dört bir yanı sarmış,
insanları bir toplasaydık.
Hayır. Verdiği demeç bu.
Ankara'ya geliyor ayağının tozuyla.
Türk halkı bir birey olmalıdır,
iyi bir eğitim almalıdır, kültürle
donatılmalıdır, bezenmelidir.
Daha meclis açılmamış.
Bunu şöyle söylüyor. Bundan sonraki
amacımız demiyor.
Bundan sonraki – altını çiziyorum –
en önemli amacımız diyor.
İşler ilginç hâle
gelmeye devam edecek.
1. İnönü, 2. İnönü çok güzel, kazandık.
Eskişehir’de bozguna uğruyoruz.
30 bin kişi askerden kaçıyor.
Yunan ordusu seferberlik ilan ediyor.
Sevr Antlaşması’nı imzalatmak için
Ankara’ya doğru yürüyüşe geçiyorlar.
Bakın ortam şu.
Meclistekiler tamamen Batı’yı
gözden çıkarmış, sinirler gergin.
Aman Batı gitti ama meclisi koruyalım.
Kayseri'ye doğru göç başlamış.
Ve o ortamda, insanların askerden
kaçtığı bir ortamda,
sağa sola kaçtığı bir ortamda,
Mustafa Kemal Atatürk altı gün boyunca
– 15-21 Temmuz 1921 –
altı gün boyunca 1. Maarif Kongresi’ni
yapıyor. Eğitim Kongresi.
Bakın ben bunu ilk duyduğumda
inanmadım. Şaka yaptıklarını zannettim.
Bu bir şaka olmalı,
bak gerçekten şaka olmalı.
Bakın ortamı bir hayal edin.
Mustafa Kemal, böyle bir ortamda,
savaş ortamında, insanlar korkuyor,
sinirler gerilmiş, göç başlamış
ve bu adam hakkında ferman var.
Fetva çıkarılmış,
yakalanırsa idam edilecek.
Ama ne yapıyor, öğretmenlerin
temsilcilerini topluyor ve diyor ki --
işte o zaman Cumhuriyet'te esas
olacak bütün eğitim ilkeleri,
temel eğitim ilkeleri,
işte o zaman atılmıştır.
Savaşın ortasında, cehennemin
ortasında, ateşten gömleği giydiği sırada.
Şimdi ben bu ülkede bahane üretmediğim
için, zorlukları, engelleri aştığım için,
tatillerimde çalıştığım için
Türkiye’de manşet oldum.
Bu adamın ülkesinde oldum.
Bu beni çok üzdü bakın.
(Alkış)
Çok teşekkür ederim.
Başka bir ülke olsa anlarım.
Ama bu adamın ülkesinde benim
manşet olmamam gerekiyordu.
Tamam, ben şimdi biraz Atatürk’ün
hayatına devam edeceğim.
Bunu bir kenarda bırakalım.
Bundan daha ilginç bir şey var.
Ne biliyor musunuz?
İzmir’in kurtuluşundan sonra etrafına
Türk ve yabancı gazeteciler toplanıyor.
Soru şu: Evet, memleketi kurtardınız,
şimdi ne yapmak istersiniz?
Yani padişah mı olacaksın,
halife mi olacaksın?
Ne cevap veriyor?
Maarif vekili olacağım,
öğretmenlik yapacağım diyor.
Şaka gibi, inanılır gibi değil.
Bakın, artık 2-3 yıl önce idam kararına
mahkûm edilmişsin, dibi görmüşsün,
ama 2-3 yıl sonra bir numaralı
adam olmuşsun artık.
Padişah da olabilirsin,
halife de olabilirsin.
Herkesi kendine kul edebilirsin,
istediğini yapabilirsin.
Diyor ki ben öğretmen olacağım.
Ben eğitimle ilgili çalışmalar yapacağım.
O çadırında konuşan insan bu işte.
En kötü anında da, en iyi anında da
hayalinden ve doğrularından vazgeçmiyor.
O içindeki çocuğu hâlâ dinliyor.
Bakın bu çok müthiş bir şey.
O güç elindeyken bunu yapabilmek.
Hatta Salih Bozok’un
hatıralarında şöyle var;
İzmir limanından
İngiliz donanması giderken,
herkes tabii bir alkış, bir kıyamet
uğurluyor, nanik yapanlar falan var.
Mustafa Kemal için ne diyor
biliyor musunuz Salih Bozok,
"Dönüp bakmadı bile" diyor.
Bak, "dönüp bakmadı bile" diyor.
Kesin, bakın ben tahmin
ediyorum ne yaptığını.
Kesin geometri kitabını düşünüyordur.
İşte buna üçgen diyeyim,
buna kare diyeyim, işte bu yuvarlak olsun.
Bak, kesinlikle böyle düşünüyordur.
Yani şöyle hayal ediyorum.
Kara tahtanın başına geçmiş
‘Ali ata bak’ yazıyor.
Diyorlar ki düşman geldi,
başkomutanlık yetkisini alayım.
(Ses yapıyor)
Ondan sonra geliyor ‘Ali ata bak’.
Oku bakayım.
Yani böyle bir askerî deha.
Tarihin gördüğü bir süngü tak emri ile
Çanakkale’nin tarihini değiştiren bu adam.
Müthiş bir askerî deha.
Askerliği hobi olarak yapıyor.
(Gülüşmeler)
Ve rahat durmuyor yine.
İzmir’in işgalinden hemen sonra
İstanbul ve Bursa'da öğretmenleri topluyor
ve onlarla bir toplantı yapıp
"Bizim kazandığımız zafer
sizin ordularınızın kazanacağı
zafere önayak olacaktır.
Sizin karşınıza çıkan bütün engelleri
kıracağız." diyor kendisi.
Hani bir Lozan Görüşmesi,
bir Cumhuriyet’i kursaydık.
Yani adam savaş ortasında, savaş bitti,
bir daha aynısını yapmaya çalışıyor.
Cumhuriyet kurulduktan
sonra ilk kurulan
mesleki ve sosyal birlik nedir
biliyor musunuz?
Muallimler Birliği.
Öğretmenler Birliği’ni kuruyor
ve orada şöyle bir sözü var.
Hani şu meşhur sözü var ya,
“Öğretmenler, yeni nesil sizin
eseriniz olacaktır’’ diye.
Bayılıyoruz bu lafa zaten.
Öğretmenler de çok bayılır.
Evet, benim eserim olacak.
Öğretmenler Günü geliyor.
Herkes paylaşır onu zaten.
Ama asıl cümlesini bu cümleden
hemen sonra söylemiştir.
Acaba kaçınız biliyor onu?
Ben burada söyleyeyim onu size,
bir öğretmen olarak.
Siz de ilkokul öğrencisisiniz
bu arada unutmayın.
Şöyle: "Öğretmenler, yeni nesil
sizin eseriniz olacaktır." Nokta.
"Eserinizin kıymeti"
– bir daha söylüyorum –
yani oluşturacağınız eserin kıymeti
– aynen böyle –
"yaptığınız fedakarlığın derecesi
ile orantılı olacaktır."
Sonra ana haberde fedakâr
öğretmen diyorlar bana.
Çok şaşırıyorlar. Neden acaba?
Bu adam söylemiş.
1924 bunu söylediğinde.
Ben mesela bazı çalışmalar yapıyorum,
bana soruyorlar, “Nasıl yaptın?”
"Bu kadar çalışmayı aynı anda
nasıl yapabiliyorsun?"
Ben diyorum ki anneleri yetiştiriyorum.
Annelerle sürekli konuşuyorum,
çatışıyorum, anlatmaya çalışıyorum.
Neden? O, bana o yıllarda söylediği için.
Bakın bir şey göstereceğim size.
Bu benim Atatürk köşem.
Ne yazık ki Selanik evinin fotoğrafı yok.
Bir şey dikkatinizi çekti mi orada?
Orada bir şey var iki tane, gördünüz mü?
İki tane madeni para koydum.
Kendi sınıfıma, Atatürk köşeme
iki tane madeni para koydum.
Neden olabilir sizce?
Çünkü Mustafa Kemal,
cebindeki son iki kuruşun
bir tanesi ile kitap alan bir adamdı.
Anıtkabir'de, sadece Anıtkabir’de
okuduğu üç bin tane kitap var.
Ben okuma alışkanlığı ile ilgili
bu vizyonu gördükten sonra
bir proje başlattım önceki sınıfımda.
Hemen onu açıklamak istiyorum.
Benim öğrencilerim NASA’nın sitesine
giriyorlardı, hacklemiyorlardı.
NASA’nın sitesine giriyorlardı, Hubble
uzay teleskobunun çektiği fotoğraflardan
– bilirsiniz o sitede çok var –
onları alıp sınıfa getiriyorlardı.
Gösteriyorlardı, şu şudur, şu budur,
arkadaşlarıyla tartışıyorlardı.
Bir tanesi bir gün dedi ki,
"Öğretmenim, bu bulutsu" dedi.
İçimden güldüm tabii.
"Oğlum" dedim,
"uzayda atmosfer yok, ne bulutsusu?"
Gerçekten bulutsuymuş
biliyor musunuz adı?
Bakın, okuma alışkanlığının, araştıran,
merak eden öğrencinin karşısında
öğretmen olarak düştüğüm duruma bak.
Yine bir gün, dinozorlarla ilgili
okuma araştırma, çocuklarla tartışıyoruz.
Herkes bir dinozor hakkında
fikirlerini söylüyor.
Benim de raptorlarla
ilgili bir zafiyetim var.
Raptorları çok seviyorum.
İşte çıktım böyle anlatıyorum.
Raptorlar böyledir, grup hâlinde
avlanır, zekâlarını kullanır.
Avına yandan darbe vurur
falan anlatıyorum.
Boyu üç metre, dört metre.
Arkadan bir el kalktı.
"Öğretmenim" dedi, "raptorların
boyu üç metreden kısa" dedi.
(Gülüşmeler)
Bak, gözünün içine baktım.
Sinirlendim, çünkü hassasım bu konuda.
(Gülüşmeler)
Hayır, ben şimdi 33 yaşındayım,
bakın 33 yaşındayım.
Benim neslim Jurassic Park’la
büyümüş nesildir.
Hani o bacak kadar çocuk gelip bana
raptorlar hakkında ahkâm kesemez.
Aynen bunu söyledim ve oturttum yerine.
(Gülüşmeler)
Sonra 2-3 hafta geçti.
Bir yerde okudum, nerede okudum,
raptorların boyu
2 metre 20 santim falan yazıyor.
Yeni bir fosil bulunmuş ve
öğrenci de yeni bilgiyi okumuş.
Ne oldu, yalan oldum.
Profesör dahi olsan okuma alışkanlığı --
işte o vizyon nereden geliyor,
işte buradan geliyor. O paradan.
Ben Selanik’in fotoğrafını asmayacağım,
kusura bakmasınlar.
Bu adam çok kitap okuyan bir adamdı.
Önce onu görsünler istiyorum.
Şimdi anlamıyorlar, bu rakamların ne
olduğunu bilmiyorlar ama anlayacaklar.
Yakında dikkat çekecekler.
Ben kitaplık yaptım diye bana gazeteci
soruyor, “Niye kitaplık yaptın?”
Okul orası işte, sınıfın içine
ben niye kitaplık yapmayayım?
Yani biraz saçma değil mi?
Ben çok şaşırdım ve bakıyorum,
böyle televizyonda izliyorum.
"Aa" diyorum, "bu konuşan ben miyim,
kekelemişim" falan diyorum böyle.
Mesela bir söz var, uzatmayayım.
“Sanatsız kalan bir toplumun hayat
damarlarından biri kopmuş demektir.”
Lafa gel! 3 boyutlu köşe var benim
sınıfımda çalışmalar için.
Resim köşesi var, sanat var,
sanatın ta kendisi var.
Bu adam söyledi işte. Sende niye yok?
"Bir gün benim sözlerimle
bilim ters düşerse
bilimi tercih edin." diyen bir adamdır bu.
Benim sınıfımda, her santimetrekaresinde
o adamın izini görürsünüz.
Fotoğrafını göremezsiniz.
Zaten kendisi söylemiyor mu,
“Benim yüzümü görmek
beni görmek değildir.
Benim fikirlerimi ve duygularımı
anlıyorsanız bu yeterlidir.” diye.
Onun bütün fikirleri ve
duyguları o sınıfın içinde.
Öleli 77 yıl olmuş, 77 yıl sonra onun
fikirleriyle, onun vizyonuyla,
onun duygularıyla yapılan bir sınıf
Türkiye’nin gündemine oturdu.
Bir asır önce yaşamış.
Peki biz neredeyiz?
Biz önümüzdeki bu değeri anlayabildik mi?
Anlayamadık, anlatamadık.
Özür dilerim anlatamadık.
Ahmet Naç olarak sıradan bir insanım.
Çıkışta gelin benimle konuşun,
beş dakika konuşun,
ne kadar sıradan bir insan
olduğumu görürsünüz.
Ama bir öğretmen olarak buradan
meydan okumak istiyorum.
O'nun cumhuriyetindeki öğretmen olarak.
Benim mezun ettiğim bir tane sınıf var.
Dört yıl boyunca beraber geçirdiğim,
mezun ettiğim bir sınıf.
O sınıfın kısa süre içerisinde
yaptıklarını yapabilecek,
dünyada herhangi bir ilkokul sınıfı varsa
ben yarın istifa edeceğim.
Ahmet hoca olarak söylemiyorum bunu.
Onun vizyonu ile onu anlamaya çalışan
bir öğretmen olarak söylüyorum.
Çıtayı çok yukarı koydum.
Sanırım belki de siz
o sınıfa baktığınız zaman,
o içinizdeki çocuk bana seslendi.
Aldığım mesajlarda onu ben gördüm.
Umudu gördüm,
o neşeyi, o hayali gördüm.
Bu insan da bu hayali
yaşayan bir insandı.
En zor anında da, en kötü anında da,
en iyi olduğu anında da,
en güçlü olduğu anında da
bu hayalinden asla vazgeçmedi.
Ben size onun en mutlu olduğu
anı göstermek istiyorum.
Sanırım bu olduğunu düşünüyorsunuz.
Yüzü çok gülüyor, ama bu anlık
bir mutluluk. Bu değil.
Onun en mutlu olduğu an,
Ordinaryüs Prof. Dr. Sadi Irmak’ın
"Atatürk’ten Anılar" adlı bir kitabı var.
O kitabında,
Behçet Kemal Çağlar’ı bilirsiniz.
Mustafa Kemal’in özellikleri
ile ilgili şiir yazar.
Bizim düştüğümüz hataya düşer.
Şöyle bir lider,
şöyle bir askerî deha der.
Alır o şiiri, bakar der ki,
“Behçet olmamış.
Benim en önemli kişiliğim,
benim asıl kişiliğim
öğretmenliğimdir.’’ der.
Bu adam, dünyanın görüp gördüğü
en büyük liderlerden biri.
Bence en büyüğü, en başarılısı,
en karizmatiği
ve gerçek bir askerî deha.
Diyor ki benim öğretmenliğimdir.
İşte onun en mutlu olduğu
fotoğraf, an işte budur.
(Alkış)
Bir gece, Çanakkale’de, çadırının içinde,
cehennemin ortasında
çizdiği o şablonu 13 yıl sonra
kara tahtada uygulayabiliyor.
Savaşlar bitmiş, cepheden cepheye
koşturmalar bitmiş.
Artık rahat ama oturmuyor bir yerlerde.
Gidiyor, kara tahtanın başında
halkını bilgilendirmeye çalışıyor.
Öğretmenlik yapıyor.
Onun asıl kişiliği
öğretmenlikti, eğitimdi.
Halkını eğitmeye çalışıyordu.
Peki biz bunu anladık mı?
Onun ülkesinde yaşayan insanlar olarak
kendimize bir pay çıkardık mı?
Son sözü O'na bırakacağım.
Ben de şu anda bir çocuk oluyorum.
Fırçamı da alıyorum.
Sizler zaten hâlâ – ders bitmedi –
ilkokul birinci sınıf öğrencisisiniz.
Bu kaydı biraz önce meydan
okuduğum sınıfa, birinci sınıftayken
sayısız kez dinletmişimdir.
Bakalım.
(Ses kaydı) (Müzik)
Çocuk: Aa...
Atatürk: Ne oldu çocuk?
Çocuk: Senin eline diken batar mı?
Atatürk: Batmaz mı?
Çocuk: Senin elin kanar mı?
Atatürk: Kanamaz mı?
Çocuk: Ama sen Atatürk değil misin?
Atatürk: Öyleyim çocuk.
Çocuk: Ama…
Atatürk: Sen şimdi bırak benim kim olduğumu.
Bu gülü yetiştireceksen
canın yanacak, elin kanayacak.
Güneş seni terletecek. Bu bahçede
gül bitmez diyenler olacak.
Gül öyle yetiştirilmez,
böyle yetiştirilir diyenler olacak.
Sen kendine şunu soracaksın.
Ben burayı gül bahçesi
yapmak istiyor muyum?
Ben burada dünyanın en güzel güllerini
yetiştirmek istiyor muyum?
Eğer çok istiyorsan ne eline batan diken
ne de söylenenler umrunda olmayacak.
Kim olursan ol, tek isteğin...
şu kokuyu duymak olacak.
Anladın mı?
Anladım.
Aferin sana. Haydi bakalım devam.
(Kayıt biter)
Ahmet Naç: Devam. Ondan ne öğrendiysem --
(Alkış)
ondan ne öğrendiysem aynısını yaptım.
Onu yaptım, fazlasını değil.
Çok teşekkürler, sağ olun.
(Alkış)